a moment of history in the heart of Kiev
able
Joe Biden all smiles but this trip took
serious risk
Vladimir zelensky shows his most
important of VIPs around
his top team Keen to say hello you've
asked me how many times have been here I
had to count even my eighth time
well it's never enough I'm looking for a
passport
wartime leaders wanting to show a united
front
[Music]
the pair emerged from a private meeting
with Mr Biden announcing new pledges of
Military Support worth half a billion
dollars
poon thought Ukraine was weak
and the West Was divided
but it's just been plain wrong
plain wrong
and one year later
the evidence is right here in this room
we stand here together
the visit by the president of the United
States to Ukraine the first in 15 years
is the essential visit of the entire
history of Ukraine U.S relations
precisely in this period because this
period is the most difficult
it's a moment that won't be forgotten
foreign
with Central cave in lockdown the two
presidents toured a landmark monastery
a moment of reflection
and then a reminder of the war
to the echo of an air raid siren they
walked to a wall where Ukraine's war
dead are remembered both paid their
respects
brief but bold encounter
[Music]
we were surprised yes but really
surprised and he
didn't know coming just ahead of the
first anniversary of Russia's full-scale
Invasion this trip appears designed to
send a clear message to Vladimir Putin
that Ukraine is still standing strong
and the United States will stand
alongside it for as long as it takes but
as the Memorial Wall illustrates the
cost already paid by this country has
been huge and the war has no end in
sight
the U.S president will be all too aware
his ability to stay the course in
Ukraine has only just begun to be tested